it is time for this week's
sin city chronicles a weekly look back
at vegas history
and happenings the 56th annual nba
all-star game was held
at the thomas and mack on february 18
2007
this was the first time the game was
held in a city without an nba franchise
the west defeated the east and the late
kobe bryant was the mvp
president's day was earlier this week
and long before he was president
ronald reagan was performing at the last
frontier
back in 1954 he did two weeks at the
hotel
and that was his opening act the marquis
chimps yep
ronald reagan was working with monkeys
that was reagan's first
and only las vegas show legendary coach
jerry tarkanian passed away in february
2015
and on february 18th the lights on the
strip went dark for three minutes to
honor the fallen coach
nearly 40 casinos and hotels
participated in the event
and prior to tarc the strip went dark
for elvis
the members of the rat pack president
kennedy reagan
and comedian george burns on february 17
2003 the las vegas gladiators made their
home debut by defeating tampa bay
61-55 the arena football team finished
their first season
eight and eight and lost in the first
round of the playoffs
february 17 2008 the wwe took over the
thomas and mack
to the no way out pay-per-view look at
that one of the highlights right here
was when floyd mayweather attacked the
big show he broke his nose right there
setting up a fight at wrestlemania oh
what a night it was
and that's your sin city chronicles for
the third week